à la fois on va parler d'une chose assez
d'événements à se voir au fait que
l'éducation ne semble pas être très
efficace pour améliorer le niveau
épistémique de la population et qui
semble qu'il ne soit nécessaire d'avoir
d'autres idées ou tout cas des choses
complémentaires puisque tant sur le
sujet plus très politisé l'éducation
semblent eux-mêmes potentiellement
néfastes notre niveau épistémique dans
le graphe du désespoir est assez
alarmiste à ce niveau là puisqu'il
semble que les opinions que se font les
gens sont d'autant plus polarisée et
même moins 500 erronée tout cas de
certaines personnes plus ils ont une
intelligence scientifique c'est
d'ailleurs une capacité à comprendre les
sciences et à appliquer des
raisonnements scientifiques dans leur
façon de penser
aujourd'hui on va voir des bonnes
nouvelles
une bonne nouvelle dans une publication
de 2017 de de dunk à rennes avec
certains de ses collègues
et cette bonne nouvelle tient en la
curiosité scientifique une curieuse
histoire de curiosité scientifique
alors comme expliquent les auteurs de
cette étude pendant longtemps et
semblait difficile de mesurer cette
curiosité scientifique mais karen et ses
collègues en fait on proposait des
métriques assez simple qui consiste
simplement à mesurer notre degré
d'intérêt en des choses scientifiques
comme des revues des émissions des
musées scientifiques opposition à
d'autres centres d'intérêts est ce qu'il
est assez malin dans cette approche
c'est que du coup les gens ne les sujets
n'ont pas l'impression qu'on ne teste
leur curiosité
ils font juste l'impression qu'on
s'informe sur eux et ça ça permet
d'avoir des données beaucoup plus
fiables sur cette mesure de la curiosité
scientifique des différentes personnes à
des différents sujets et alors je vous
passe le quelques détails sur comment on
calcule tout ça le degré de fiabilité
qui a l'air vraiment vraiment bon ce qui
est vraiment intéressant avec cela c'est
que ce qu'ils ont observé de façon ces
données observationnelles donc ces
sujets à tous les facteurs de confusion
par doc simpson et tout ça mais il se
trouve que sur les données observées
observational ce qu'il constate c'est
que le degré de croyance en la phrase il
y à des données solides en faveur d'un
changement climatique d'origine
anthropique ses croyances là vont dans
le même sens quels que soient les partis
politiques
plus on est curieux plus on a tendance à
converger vers cette enfin l'acceptation
de cette phrase
et ça c'est vraiment intéressant parce
que ça c'est vraiment que ça va à
l'encontre de tant de données
déprimantes qui montrait que 7,7 princes
avec ans plus tôt à diverger
par exemple on était intelligent puis
ont été cultivés plus vous mettez
influents ou autre chose
dit autrement ils sont quelques restée
soit peut-être la solution pour
combattre la polarisation et le
raisonnement motivé
dès que les sujets sont très politisés
une explication avancée à ce phénomène
parmi tant d'autres français mans mais
une explication avancée par les auteurs
c'est le fait que possiblement les
personnes qui sont plus curieuse point
de scientifiques sont plus à même
d'aller chercher l'information qui les
surprend qui leur fait apprendre quelque
chose y compris quand ces informations
vont à l'encontre de leurs préférences
politiques pour tester ses épaules cette
hypothèse les auteurs de l'étude ont
fait une expérience randomisée contrôlée
ou l'idée c'était d'exposer les sujets à
une proposition de deux articles aliern
une qui est classique équivalent dans
leur centre qui de la forme une puce
finir mes études confirment que
blablabla et une autre étude qu'elle est
surprenante et ne va pas dans leur sens
qu'il est plus du genre
contre toute attente les scientifiques
ont découvert que blablabla et je vous
invite à faire expand nous sommes donc
si vous êtes là j'imagine que vous avez
tendance à croire au changement
climatique
est ce que si vous voyez un article qui
dit quelque chose comme 2 2 contre toute
attente la fonte des glaces en arctique
n'est pas si rapide que ça est ce que ça
vous donne envie de lire cet article
parce que vous aurez envie plus haut 2
de données de gestion en dix ans dans
l'expression au changement climatique
est il très important ça crée des carres
et j'ai pas envie de lire rsa qui quelle
est votre réaction à l'idée de
l'exposition potentielle à ce genre
d'article pas personnellement moi dans
le cas du coc vide c'est quelque chose
que j'ai beaucoup observé j'ai beaucoup
d'avenir touche très intelligente comme
beaucoup d'autres de très intelligent en
pression sera scientifique et tout ça et
dès le début de la crise ou avant la
crise
il avait quand même un parti un peu pris
du genre ouais c'est quand même moins
les gens sous-estiment à quel point
c'est mon choix ou des gens surestiment
à quel point c'est dangereux et ce qui
m'a plu nous fera beaucoup c'est que
dans ce genre de débat que j'ai qui dure
sur plusieurs mois avec ces personnes là
c'est assez fréquent que les les
interlocuteurs donc bon à chaque fois
swing et des arguments qui vont
uniquement dans le saut dans le monde en
leur sens c'est à dire que sur
l'ensemble de tous les articles qui ont
été publiés dans choses qui ont été
dites sur le co lead ils vont avoir
tendance à 6 si c'était un peu plus
catastrophistes avant de partager que
des truites qui montrent qu'elle est
vraiment c'est horrible les données qui
montrent que c'est vraiment horrible et
à ne pas partager les
les bonnes nouvelles pendant que le fait
que la corée du sud a quasiment anéantie
à la pandémie énormément contrôler très
très très vite ça c'est une excellente
nouvelle mais ça pas été forcément
partagé par c'est par ces personnes qui
étaient plus catastrophistes la même
façon cet été va les nombres ducobu donc
quand même pas mal d'aider ces sas a pas
été forcément mis en avant par ces
personnes-là est inverse les gens qui
disaient non mais c'est pas si grave ya
des fausses pire attention à l'économie
tout ça mais ils avaient plus tendance à
partager des choses qui ont montré que
c'était pas si horrible et à ne pas
partager les la nouvelle croissance
exponentielle qui a eu cet automne où
les différents emballement de
désinformation qui sont extrêmement
préoccupants alors qu'est ce que ça
donnait pour les sujets de l'étude
eh bien on leur a proposé deux articles
le premier temps intitulé les
scientifiques ont trouvé de nouvelles
données surprenantes les glacier en
antarctique sont en fait en train de
grossir et ne contribue donc pas à la
montée du niveau des océans
le deuxième article qu'il aurait été
proposé a contrario disait que les
scientifiques ont trouvé toujours plus
de données qui lie le changement
climatique à des conditions
météorologiques extrêmes
si vous deviez choisir entre ces deux
articles lequel de ces deux articles
choisiriez vous et surtout d'après vous
lequel de ces deux articles ont choisi
les sujets de l'étude et bien parmi les
sujets avec une faible curiosité
scientifique comme on pouvait s'y
attendre le choix de l'article et
dépendent fortement des convictions
politiques du lecteur
les individus beaucoup plus républicains
sont ainsi beaucoup plus tenté par la
lecture des données surprenantes qui
vont dans le sens de leurs convictions
alors que les démocrates eux ont en fait
très peu de chances que s'intéresser à
ces nouvelles données qui contredisent
leur intuition et ont plus de chances de
s'intéresser au sujet qui va confirmer
leurs convictions même s'ils ne vont a
priori pas apprendre quelque chose de
nouveau à ce sujet ok ça c'est parmi les
individus avec une faible curiosité
scientifique mais qu'en est il des
sujets avec une grande curiosité
scientifique et bien de façon
remarquable on voit que l'intérêt pour
ces sujets est beaucoup plus grands
poètes donnée surprenante que ces
individus soient démocrates ou
républicains la curieuse des
scientifiques incitent tout le monde à
s'intéresser à ceux qui vont
prendre même si ceux qui vont apprendre
à de bonnes chances d'aller à l'encontre
de leurs convictions politiques
alors pour vérifier qu'il n'ya pas ici
une asymétrie entre les démocrates et
les républicains
les auteurs de l'étude ont proposé à
d'autres sujets un autre foi d'articles
où les rôles entre républicains et
démocrates sont inversés en l'occurrence
il s'agissait désormais de choisir entre
un article qui dit que la glace en
arctique est en train de fondre plus
rapidement que ce qui est prévu un
article qui dit que les scientifiques
ont tous prouvé toujours plus de données
qui disent que le changement climatique
en fait ralenti au cours de la dernière
décennie encore une fois par une île
électeurs avec une faible curiosité
scientifique l'impact de leurs
convictions politiques est important
plus les individus sont républicains -
ils ont des chances de s'exposer à des
données surprenantes qui vont à
l'encontre de leurs convictions
politiques épuisées moins de chances de
se renfermer sur les données qui
conforte leur intuition
cependant parmi les sujets avec une
grande curiosité scientifique de façon
assez surprenante
il se trouve que les républicains avec
une grande curiosité scientifique ont
d'autant plus de chances de s'intéresser
à ces données surprenantes
en fait même plus encore que les
démocrates alors pourquoi c'est
difficile à expliquer mais peut-être une
explication possible c'est le fait que
cette donnée est particulièrement
surprenante pour la république un et les
moins pour les démocrates
quoi qu'il en soit on a là une étude
assez stupéfiante sur la capacité de la
curiosité scientifique et nous
intéresser à des données surprenantes
y compris quand ces données surprenantes
vont à l'encontre de ce qu'on aimerait
penser
bref cette étude qui est non seulement
une étude je pense que c'est un truc qui
va encore creuser alors j'adore le fait
que les auteurs de l'étude
eux mêmes ne mettent beaucoup ça en
avant et se fume beaucoup le jeu était
curieux de leur propre découverte
ça m'a fait face à ces régions
appliquent leur trophée est d'ailleurs
devenu lors des couleurs savoir propre
écriture de l'article c'est ça je trouve
ça génial et en tout cas cessé ses
trouvailles me vont beaucoup augmenter
ma crédence en l'importance de curiosité
et je pense que c'est donc très
important qu'on la mette beaucoup plus
en avant qu'on valorise beaucoup plus et
pour cela je vous recommande vivement
les chaînes qui promeut vaut mieux mieux
que résister à mon sens par exemple
celle de dax et haute de patrick boos la
chaîne de michael launay la chaîne de
syllabus de viviane c'est ça c'est des
chaînes qui sont vraiment des bijoux de
curiosité moi personnellement préféré
bon je sais c'est pas forcément
porte-monnaie ccib voir ses vidéos mais
c'est c'est une bouffée d'oxygène de
curiosité cents
c'est tellement ça me donne tu vaux par
reste ça renouvelle toute ma curiosité
scientifique et je sens que j'en ai
besoin régulièrement quand c'est pas
quelque chose que c'est quelque chose
qui se perd en temps dans des périodes
de ses traits tendus d'un point de vue
politique je pense que c'est très
important de remettre en avant est de
faire un travail sur soi même pour
promouvoir cette curiosité et puis pour
pouvoir auprès des autres et du coup je
pense que je les encourage vivement à
aller voir ses chaînes ou hadji aussi
assez des chaînes qui en fait sont
accablants utile pour une espèce
d'hygiène épistémique qui ensuite est
critique pour pouvoir bien interpréter
les choses réfléchir plus calmement dans
des périodes où c'est beaucoup plus
tendue d'un point de vue politique
et à l'échelle collective je pense que
c'est très important de trouver des
manières de mettre des coups puissants
avant cette curiosité scientifique
surtout dans les sujets politisé et ça
ça passe par chacun d'entre nous on est
chacun un maillon d'une chaîne
d'information donc si on peut relayer
les choses qui suscite plus cette
curiosité plutôt que de toujours
chercher à défendre son son petit
morceau ce qui peut nous y aider
nous-mêmes et biaisé notre entourage
vers du raisonnement motivé je pense
qu'il faut célébrer beaucoup plus saine
curiosité scientifique en tout cas c'est
ce que suggère très vivement cette
marque publication que vous invite à
lire par ailleurs